welcome to another episode of the
Streamy award winning podcast not too
deep I'm your host grace and Helbig and
I'm very excited to have Nolan Gould on
this episode he is I mean you know him
from Modern Family
you might not know him from social media
because he doesn't really actively
participate in it he's one of those like
healthy humans that has a life outside
the internet but we got to learn a lot
about that life in this episode he loves
to rock climb he's an actual genius so
watch this really smart well-adjusted
young successful person make me feel
wonderfully inadequate this whole
episode of not too deep enjoy here we go
my son yeah they have therapy pets this
is your therapy pet and it got even
worse when I looked at the face yeah
but this baby somehow has been in front
of a medium that was checking a bunch of
dolls that were like supposedly haunted
and they we threw this baby in the mix
of them and the guy said he called out
all the other dolls that were haunted
and said that this one has seen only
good fun times so this one is not
haunted and it's not dangerous so I
trust that person they might also have
just been a fan of your podcast
well I literally was like this is a risk
throwing this in because if they tell me
that this doll is haunted it is going in
a dumpster somewhere you know do you
watch like John Oliver yes John Oliver
had a bit about mediums oh really I
haven't seen that bit now yeah it's
awesome
really they're like the worst people oh
yeah
there's also um the amazing Randi have
you seen that documentary no it's this
guy that literally like has dedicated
his whole life to like calling out
people on their like magic [ __ ] and
like psych whatever psychic medium kind
of [ __ ] and it's pretty great
yeah highly recommend if you're into
documentaries yeah I am obviously
documentaries that
it makes me feel good I mean chicken
people I'll recommend that one that
one's really good some people that
compete have competitive chicken
competitions like like dog shows but for
chickens like a 4h yep and the chickens
you know fairly are beautiful like they
are really gorgeously sexy sexy sexy
begins I think was the first title of
you guys are running recorder we're
already rolling we're in it now no.1
thank you for being here
oh we actually are house good thanks for
having me of course you're a busy busy
boy yeah yeah although not right now
we're on we're on season break between
season 10 and 11 okay I'm unemployed
right now really looking for employment
I know it feels it feels good we worked
really hard for eight months
yeah to bring to bring comedy yeah
peoples of the world and yeah it's just
it's nice good a little bit of a break
what do you well the one thing I saw
when I was like I said before stalking
your social media um you do a lot of
rock climbing and things like that in
your free time
yeah how did that start um how did that
start Oh me and my friend were really
into like a Netflix show called like
ultimate beast master if you haven't
watched it it's wonderful okay it really
is it's like people from the 8 different
country isn't like the I have hosts for
like each different country and they're
like cheering on like them as they
basically run like an American Ninja
Warrior coat of course but hey the
ultimate speed ultimate beast master
it's just so silly and the people that
always win that competition are rock
climbers really yeah because they just
have like you know amazing arm strength
and like control they were like beating
out you know martial artists and stuff
like that soon my friend were like yo if
we ever want to run the ultimate beast
master course which are highly
considering yeah as an option in my life
okay
we've got to become rock climbers okay
watching like the big string of movies
that came out about Rocklin me like free
so long yeah I haven't seen that yeah I
hear it's always great there's also one
called the dawn wall okay um both both
really great and that just kind of
further cementing us into rock climbing
and so that's how you started with the
goal of becoming the ultimate that's
what do they win on that show pride I
think yeah I think yeah you went you
went like a monetary prize but like then
you get to like put like beast like my
twitter handle is getting changed like
at beastly what's your relationship well
because okay you started this is my deep
dive not so deep pretty shallow dive of
you started a separate Instagram that's
specifically for your rock climbing
endeavors yeah what is your relationship
with Instagram as a whole bailout it's
um I've got like a weird relationship
with Instagram obviously like I I kind
of need it because that's just where the
industry is going right now you already
have like followers and stuff like that
but I don't have besides my new
Instagram account which is I'm totally
gonna plug it right now please do it's
the only only form of social media I
enjoy it's called free nolo mm-hmm a lot
like free solo but um yeah that's see if
it wasn't for that like I wouldn't I
don't have personal social media gotcha
I'm not on Facebook because like they
steal my information and like sell it
Russia yes I do oh yeah we're going
political media yeah I'm just I'm not on
social media it's it's so hard for me I
don't get it yeah really yeah I just
think I do you follow is there anyone
that you follow on social media that you
look at on social media or is it just
kind of like a vacuum uh I do for like
mindless like entertainment yeah
although I do follow like social media
can be cool like I felt like NatGeo and
stuff oh you're a good
you know like charities and stuff you
don't follow like any French bulldogs
no I don't know like Instagram can go
either way
really really you can do good things or
can I just learned we just had someone
on that was telling me that they started
doing favorites or I didn't know you
could do this on Instagram where you can
like save people's posts and then when
they feel like bad about the world and
about like social media they just go to
their personal favorites page and it's
just flooded with all of like their
actual it's like a Pinterest page
basically but on Instagram and I was
like yeah that's the better way to use
social media than to just get sucked
into like now I'm like in year 2015 on
some random Instagram model that I don't
know and I don't know how I got here
yeah I just I if I do go on like social
media I have to stay very far away from
the direct messages oh yes yes that's it
that's a dark place yes like change very
rapidly like when I hit like 19 or 20
yeah like the direct messages the
content that was in there changed really
yeah I'm sure had a different meaning
I always fall for it to they'll be like
this person sent you a photo I'm like I
don't like photos of a dog like no video
of them rock climbing but people can see
in those dams if you screenshot what
they say oh really what were used during
shouting a guy that I was you know
having a situation with like a romantic
situation that wasn't really going
anywhere and then I screen shouted the
message and send it to my friend and the
next message I got from him is why did
you screenshot this I'm not asking for a
new screenshot is it the text or is it I
think it's anything in the message that
you screenshot that you know how you can
see when something has been seen it's
seen underneath of it
it says like this isn't screen shot well
that explains thank god this dude
immediately we came back was like why
did you screenshot this I threw my phone
out the window yeah if I don't look at
it that means he's never looked at it
either all good boy so what do you do
you do is rock climbing kind of you're
like go to and like your hiatus time
yeah I mean very very recently yeah
although I've been getting just like
super super messed up from rock climbing
toward like a like a minute in my ankle
and like broke a rib oh sure not from
rock climbing but it you know as has
been affecting that it's just rock
climbing is such a good like it's a
mental game it is it's both a physical
and like mental because you're solving a
puzzle and they also like I love being
in nature you travel a lot I do yeah but
it's also really difficult for me too
especially living in Los Angeles which
is just kind of like a concrete like
jungle
yes surrounding you for like miles hmm
it's hard to get like the motivation to
get outside and like I don't want to go
like hike like Runyon Canyon matches a
hiking trail in that way that's
basically a paved path yeah yeah so rock
climbing is always like really good
excuse like drive out to a national park
and just like be outside doing something
yeah cuz weren't you just in the Grand
Canyon yeah I was just in the Grand
Canyon actually with my uh my TV dad ty
burrell oh you guys travel together on a
rafting Misun rafting trip oh wait no I
did see a video of you getting like
pulled out of the water by him or
something just got a text from him last
night about it which by the way the fact
that me and Ty Burrell like Texas yeah
it makes me happy it's very silly
matambi said hey hey young man how are
you
remember when we almost died in the
Grand Canyon together what happened cuz
you ain't looked intense were you
wearing a body camera oh yeah I was
wearing I was wearing a GoPro yeah and
yeah I I kind of just they had like
inflatable kayaks and one label complain
about yeah it's just like a rubber kayak
okay Phil there mm-hmm and I jumped in
one day and I had been whitewater
kayaking before
but only in my class 3 class more Rapids
and these were Class eight Rapids what's
the maximum class I don't death like
Niagara Falls and I just hopped in like
like our River guides were awesome but
they also like there they've done it so
many times that they can't keep it it's
like like hey can you tell me how to get
through this rap and they're like oh
yeah man there's gonna be like a lot of
phasing lateral and you're gonna see
like a big hole in the water you don't
want to go to the right of the rock but
left of the hole this means nothing to
you and you're like literally a foot
above the water you can't see anything
it's um like massive waves coming at ya
and we were on this one called house
rock rapid which is famous for being
literally how size rock down at the
bottom and when the water goes over this
rock it creates like a big divot in the
water a gigantic hole okay fifteen feet
by 15 feet and you don't want to follow
him there cuz that's like that that's
the end yeah you know you don't come out
of there God and uh I was I was like
looking around for this whole I'm like I
don't see I don't see it I saw a big
wave to my left I was like I'm kind of
go to the right of that and like as I
went past it I look to my left and like
I look like seven feet down into the
water and saw like my life that's
terrifying was there what is the
precursor for allowing you to have this
inflatable raft you just go I've done
this before they're like here you go
yeah
they don't test any of your skills there
anything no none whatsoever that's nuts
wait so then you fell in and then fell
in cup and then your TV dad pulled you
my TV dad pulled me out and I guess I
didn't realize I was down feel like I
got sucked down for like 15 seconds and
that's horrifying and apparently uh tie
his wife told me afterwards that like
tie just like he lost it in a way that
like he literally that's just something
not even like a my son just like he went
like stone cold and just like stared
into the water
that was uh but I basically spent like
the rest of the trip being like a wet
cat because the waters like verse 52
degrees and I was down in it for like a
minute and so I got out like oh my god
that's nuts now you guys have formed a
deeper bond than you probably ever could
a totally thanks for now you owe him one
life saving I'm on it yeah also like
I'll be America's hero if I save TVs ty
burrell oh my god I'm telling about you
it's so sweet that you guys actually
just like hang out outside the show that
you're not totally sick of each other
yeah I mean well I mean we are a family
in like every sense of the word spent 10
years together so like there are moments
where I might get me away yeah sure it's
like you know we uh we grew up together
and sometimes like yeah there you spend
every day with these people but at the
same time like you have a bond that's
like so much
it's art described it's literally just a
family yeah have you fully processed
that the end is the end is coming winter
is coming I can't do Game of Thrones
spoilers listening to anything no yeah I
the funny thing is I've never been able
like even now it seems so far away
because our show has always been like
such a like a state like it we always
have known it's coming back like there's
never never been like a doubt near me
yeah yeah I think like season four I was
like hey just in cases like show ends
like I better start like coming up with
a plan of what I want to do I was like
I'll get it to it get some kind of
absence of a plan out but I don't know
if part of me still like always sings
like Barnaby always gonna like get
picked up by a dog yeah we're gonna be a
spin-off or something Luke's gonna be
like 40 by the time the shower yeah
there you go would you do it a Luke
spin-off yeah absolutely I have no other
plans I will do anything this probably
doesn't help me like as far as I can ago
she ate and goes because this can
totally like
used to gain speed by a network but look
at how eager you were to be like if I
tried like I don't know you'll have to
make it worth my while we have the
greatest job in the world yeah I must
say I mean it's from I follow a lot of
you guys on Instagram and I've like
worked with Sarah before and like it
just seems like you guys are just
genuinely like having a great time yeah
but it doesn't it must not feel like
work all day and you guys all seem like
genuinely kind humans that like care for
each other and like well you're wrong
yeah I think it's really difficult
especially nowadays to find a community
in the industry that like what we have
going on mm-hmm
I don't think you find it anymore
because it's kind of like the end of the
era of like a long time running like
family like sitcoms yeah and even like
shows nowadays especially like um you
know with everything that's going on
with streaming like shows just don't
last longer anymore you know yeah
there's less of that I think because
like amount of family has always felt so
secure that like Kyra's just be like oh
no it's just like our day job like we're
not there like panicking like guys we
gotta like step it up or else it's just
like such a relaxed environment where we
really get to go and just like I know
it's awesome it seems really great and I
think that's what resonates too is that
you guys all seem like genuinely like
grateful for the work and like enjoy it
and that's like you know half the battle
yeah the other half is getting it on
yeah what's the what's the fan base like
I you know I'm actually still
discovering like new things about the
fan base all the time I just found out
like a modern family has like a fan like
wiki it's always like I cannot find like
the right word to describe it yesterday
but it was just like a huh for me for me
like people like watch this like they
really like because like I don't I'm I'm
not I'm not like a big fan of like I'm
not a TV guy sure so like you know when
shows get big I'm not like really aware
of it I've never been like part of that
like the crazy yeah the friends people
or whatever
so it's kind of just like crazy to me
the idea that our show has kind of
become that to people and they were
literally people who like to sit down
like write articles about every episode
Wow I wrote like an article like
describing my character which of course
I was like that's not right just a jerk
but this is a lot more going on about me
and I was actually I was super happy
about it because yesterday I was looking
for something to post on social media
about our episode that's coming up and I
didn't I didn't have any photos cuz I
never take any photos I never asked for
them I'm just I'm really bad at it so I
just googled like Modern Family new
episode photos like thank God for the
superfans I don't know how they find
this stuff like before me like I feel
like I should I should have already in
your cam yeah they're like they're
talking about like storylines for like
Luke next season I'm like how do you
know this they don't tell me lies yeah
so things shout out to the superfans wow
that's so cool
and also you'll never have to take a
photo again oh no it's great
oh yeah oh my my social media is now
just becoming like a posting platform
I'm just gonna like I'm gonna like hire
on all these super fans I'm not gonna
hire them because they're super fans so
great job and thank you I was like one
of your photos if you write a caption
for me if you suddenly start becoming
very active on social media we know that
it's completely outsourced not doing any
wonders for my social media I don't
think you know what that no agency was
really cool I'm gonna go give him a
fallout nope not worth your time this is
the PSA unfollow unfollow get it
trending oh I love it okay we're gonna
take a quick break when we get back I
gotta talk to you about go-karting as
Pikachu and you know your other travel
endeavors so I'll be right back with
more now Judy
[Music]
too deep this episode not too deep is
supported you will understand that pun
in a second by one of my favorite
companies third love with more than 70
sizes including their signature half cup
sizes third love designs bras with
breast size and shape in mind for a
perfect fit and premium feel you just
answer a few simple questions via third
loves fit finder quiz to find your
perfect fit in 60 seconds and then
thinks the third loves 100% fit
guarantee you can wear wash and put your
bra to the test for 60 days I'm talking
about two months people and if you don't
love it you can return it and third
level wash it and donate it to a woman
in need this is hands-down the most
comfortable bra that you will ever own
they have straps that don't slip they
have tag list labels they're lightweight
super thin memory foam cups it's all
wonderful and you're hearing this
straight from the mouth of a girl that
lives resides thrives in only sports
bras for the majority of her life and
these bras are exceptionally comfortable
their love knows that there's a perfect
bra for everyone so right now they're
offering you beautiful listeners 15% off
your first order go 2/3 love.com slash
grace now to find your perfect fitting
bra and get 15% off your first purchase
that's third love.com such grace for 15%
off today send gifts or tips of myself
to such a novel thing you're like me
you've probably been [ __ ] for the last 10
years never just makes me think of like
what else I'm missing out there oh I'm
sure there's like modern family like
memes you know I actually have read the
modern family fiction fan fiction I've
written some of it myself it's it's as
horrifying as you would think yeah I'm
sure it gets into some dark alleys of
the mind that you don't want to
entertain I don't wanna go too deep into
it but there's the my least favorite
where I ever found what's called
family fun feel free to cut that out
oh no that's in yeah I've read fanfics
have my friends and I where I've gotten
my best friend pregnant and then like
got shot or no she's gotten me pregnant
and then I've been shot with a gun and I
died in her arms or something like that
yeah it gets pretty
I mean it's there's creativity to it but
it it's maybe too much creativity okay
let's talk about Tokyo you were just in
Tokyo yeah you go carted around dressed
as Pikachu I did oh my god I was it I
was a bigger celebrity dressed up as
Pikachu than I was just myself it's yeah
you go kart around Tokyo and you dress a
Middle East outfit since wait you
suppose it sounds did you decide to
dress up in the outfits or the go-kart
have a bunch of different outfits both
me and my friend were like I mean I was
like I'm gonna be Pikachu he's like I'm
gonna be Pikachu it's like neither
rusted budge so we both winners Pikachu
like us together absolutely killed it oh
yeah we really at one point stop til I
get out and walk around and like for a
15 minute straight you were thinking
good thing like we're outside of like
Grauman's Chinese Theater all the people
dressed up as you know like Johnny Depp
impersonators that was us technically
charged no it was like probably one of
the highlights in my life was riding
around um in a freaking go-kart yeah
through the streets of Tokyo yeah that's
amazing
we're all so few travelled I feel like I
mean you probably that must be instead
of using social media you actually use
it to go see the world with your
eyeballs yeah I see I see with my
eyeballs yeah yeah I've been a lot of
places I think I met like 25 countries
and watching yeah what's your short list
of where you want to go short list of
where I want to go oh god it's such a
long list I'm sure
didja today I really want to go to Nepal
oh I've never been yeah Nepal and butan
yeah like the kind of Himalayan
countries cool um yeah where I was I'm a
huge scuba diver so oh nice
anywhere there I'm oh I'm going to
Indonesia next year to like live on
about for a week I go diving and then
they drop you off in this island that's
really cool that it's okay I'm just
giving you so many recommendations yeah
yeah from this documentary called racing
extinction and basically they found this
low island that was hunting manta rays
and selling their fins to China for like
the black market fin trade and they
convinced all the locals to stop hunting
the manta rays and now instead they all
work as Park Rangers and they protect
the manta rays and you can go and stay
on a resort there and see only resort in
the world we're building it actually
increased biodiversity in the area Wow
so you get to go and like I don't know
go stay on a private island but also
like support like you know vandalism and
like these people to make sure that they
don't go back to like hunting man
tourism that's incredible awesome that's
super cool what a great recommendation
and you you're going there next year
yeah nice well the mean put it on the
gram okay you were on Worst Cooks in
America
oh boy man I've got I think I still have
a scar on my finger it's really cutting
it open with a knife I really am a
terrible terrible cook this opportunity
or did you see they had you know what
they had heard of my prowess was the
worst cook in America and surprising
like it's it's a competition show and
the competition I found out later on was
not to be the worst cook in America the
worst I got that too many oh this and no
you like the goal is to start really bad
and then like improve okay that did not
happen
again I lost on pizza but how do you
lose on pizza
I don't cuz Beach is meant to be bought
and not made yeah exactly yeah he's
meant to get delivered yeah I did I who
else was on there was LaToya Jackson
Oscar Nunez who plays Oscar from the
office I in irons earring and sharknado
oh yeah looks like it should be Ian but
it's well that's fun so you took away no
new skill sets
no none so ever no whatsoever I uh I
recently learned how to use a crock-pot
oh that's cool yeah I didn't forget it
just like I am the king of like single
dude living right now I just bought like
a whole bunch of peanut butter because
that's dinner grab a jar of peanut
butter you got a spoon there's no mess
but keeps you fast I mean you should
have a lifestyle brand I don't know why
I don't have a cooking show just teach
you how to like really spice up that
like instant ramen do you still you
lived with your brother you might be
okay this is sometimes my brother lives
with me okay this is a it's a very small
distinction it's what keeps everything
together you know stops like our house
from devolving into like primal like
madness okay yeah and how long has this
been happening yeah there's been uh two
and a half years okay I think have you
guys said around like house rules yeah
our house rules are like god they're so
weird like they all having a weird story
where you're like why I'm like why is
SunnyD band actual genuine question why
is he man I don't know because like when
we first moved out like I went like
straight to like kind of like um
narcissistic dictator
my house my rules like bad sunny because
like me and my brother went shopping cuz
we didn't have any food in the house and
we had he wanted to get SunnyD I was
like no to get orange juice cuz I'm not
gonna drink a Sunny D it's like it's
gross it was orange juice today or
injures he's like I want so needy and I
just ban so needy on this that are you
have you and your brother been close
growing up here and there we were really
close an age for like 14 months apart
okay we had like a pretty big sibling
rivalry thing I think growing up okay
but like on a massive scale like because
both me and him we're members of Mensa
which is like a high IQ Society is so
like so you're both members we're both
members immense two kids and they were
both immense like I'm [ __ ] they're
smarter than me my brother when did an
IQ testing got 149 okay
I went and got an IQ test and got a 150
this jerk went back and retested I don't
know how I can get meat accident got 151
I saw it just we're like like one up in
each other and then like it just
continued on to like that you know like
I'm on an award winning yeah we never
beat each other out we just had like
brain battles yeah like brain waves at
each other have you come back and retake
good test I did I like I deteriorated
three points
yeah but it was like alpha like a pocket
IQ test that someone bought me for my
like birthday or something so how do you
get into men's that like you take the
test then is there like a welcoming
ceremony yeah you know actually
Professor X finds a cerebro that's the
chamber he said to me he's like there's
enough
that's a good question I don't I don't
know how but yeah you take the test you
get to join the super secret Club yeah
you get like a certificate yeah and then
you all sit around and you plot like the
destruction of the world worth saving it
I mean you guys are the ones I David
it's really not like that at least for
for kids it was a lot of like hanging
out like Dungeons & Dragons and you guys
actually go and you meet with each other
yeah it works at all obviously it's a
really cool resource for like yeah like
really smart kids who like have trouble
fitting in okay but there were there
were a few moments where like I was I
gotta get out I'm on like the lower
spectrum I'm smart but I can still kind
of like seamlessly blend in with people
yeah I remember like watching a kid get
up in front of all of us for like
show-and-tell as he perceived to name
off every font in the world
he was like Cambria Calabria times x
near oh man I would have loved to be a
fly on the wall for that like yeah yeah
by the way it makes no sense but that
kid is an absolute player right now that
really came in handy in high school all
the girls you know who would have
thought that millenials just love do you
guys still keep in touch me and anybody
from net world no I just I actually feel
like I kind of like have just been
purposely like dumbing myself down okay
you talked about your brother and you
guys him living with you what's your
house aesthetic like um trash okay she's
like
garbage everywhere like we don't we're
learning how to like take care of
ourselves like this I kind of jumped
like straightens like the deep end of
the swimming pool okay like I moved out
when I was 17 and like didn't know how
to cook don't know how to like clean
mm-hmm and that stuff so like it's been
a process like thankful for YouTube for
like you know teach me how like fix
things around the house and it's like
it's slowly getting there but like there
was a while we're like we didn't have
like plates we actually just got plates
last year for my birthday Ariel winter
my sister on the show who is just like
one of the best people in the world just
bought me like an entire kitchen set
yeah and cuz like like she came over for
like a dinner party I made like paper
plates so like we didn't even have cops
we would just drink from the faucet so
we're very very slowly getting there
you're slowly evolving yeah oh that's
very nice and also how kind of Ariel to
she's the best
yeah yeah what was her I mean you were
what ten when you started the show what
was your first impression of everyone oh
that's a good question um I mean it's
also an impression from a 10 year old
yeah well it was funny I knew Rico
before because Manny
we were actually in an acting class
together oh really um yeah and of course
if you go to that acting classes website
we're the first two things I already
knew Rico now it's pretty awesome when
we were going to like we'd see each
other at like callbacks and stuff you
know the fact that we both got it was
really cool how was I was like super
intimidated by everybody I remember um
like at the first table were you calling
Tai and Julie mr. Birrell and mrs. Bowen
yeah you got dropped that right now
yeah you know it was being a
ten-year-old walking to like a super
adult world but so it was a little
intimidated but and super lucky that
like everyone on like the setter just
like everyone's kind yeah yeah such good
people and really like worked out for
the kids growing up yeah nothing you
spent 10 years of your life on this say
well yeah it's also not said like you
know we actually did account recently of
how many plike kids we've had on the
show because you know we've added like
some as the season goes on and yeah
we've had a lot and the fact that none
of them have gone like Lindsay Lohan you
because are like talking to you and
hearing that you're just like a normal
person that likes to be outdoors and
isn't like chained to your social media
like yeah this is refreshing and wonder
oh man I'm just like I'm starting to
like feel old like not to go back to the
social media thing back when I'm like
social media recently and I was like I
was accounting it was just like all
interviews were like these young like
vine stars instagramers and I didn't
like I didn't get it one of them was
like wearing like like a Gucci backpack
like front yet so you could like I think
there's clearly like nothing in there I
swear to god you can't hide like diamond
braces or I'm like it was a grill but it
was also braces I was like what the hell
am I looking at this is like like is
this give me the rest of my life just
feeling all the I just like I felt tired
I wanted likes it braking creatures I'm
looking at where did it crawl out from
under like where are their parents oh I
want you to just follow me around and
comment on social media near me all the
time those are the exact identical
thoughts I have really like I got till I
kind of grew up in like the last segment
of society that's gonna grow up turn out
to be cool as far as I'm concerned you
like it like these like like you seven
year olds who like know how to like use
like social media and like I think it's
better than I do like I grew up in
Phoenix City Alabama okay and like like
I don't know I think I ran around
barefoot
I was like you were a natural child yeah
wild child you like played in the
extremes and stuff and like our first
computer was a Windows - mm-hmm they
already have entire windows that help
but like we learned like the only games
I ever played were like weird like math
games and I'm okay so that's how you
grew up how did you transition into
acting and getting into that world that
but we actually started acting out and
Phoenix City Alabama and believe it or
not not a huge acting capital of the
world
it does not go fast Angeles New York
Phoenix City and we kind of just start
any community theater out there um that
is a very southern thing I can't say
theater Peter like it doesn't focus my
mind I have say theater
oh yes I still think a little bit of
creep and sometimes but yeah my brother
and me who were super advanced my mom
enrolled us in like community theater
and and this is funny uh then my first
role ever was you remember like a boxcar
children our children hmm I'm like there
was a dog called watch and I that was my
first role ever but I didn't I didn't
even get the character of watch all to
myself I had to split part half the time
with another can everyone starts
somewhere stars they're just like us oh
speaking of music the logic music video
mmm that's nuts how did that come about
um super last minute oh yeah yeah I got
like call from my manager like hey do
you want to like go be at a logic
amusing video it was like uh yeah and
she was like cool it's in an hour it's
like oh my god wait you gotta call it
day uh yeah day off and they had never
I'd never heard that song before yeah I
was only doing it cuz I'm a big Khalid
fan hmm then I heard Khalid was in the
music video and I just want to meet
Khalid I still have it and there's like
I was hoping I could meet Oh Oh cuz I
just feel like we'd get each other you
know I feel like like Khalid just means
like like a real guy to like sit him
down and be like nah man like you know
God worry about all these like crazy
like
he's got too many yes men in his life
just these like a real guy you know I've
like worry about all these rap politics
and stuff I got you man
yeah and so yeah I went and did this
this music video and the song is about
the suicide hotline and suicide
prevention and it's really crazy because
I think now it's at like 300 million
views or something it's like 400 and we
just were watching yeah it's like 400
something it's inside you look like that
gives me anxiety I mean that's so crazy
it's so many people yeah and I assuming
that no one had any Inklings that that
was gonna happen no I had no idea yeah
and then like I think they performed it
at the Grammys and everyone was like
wearing t-shirts about like the hotline
like I think like in the wake of that
music video coming out like the hotline
like percentage of calls went up like 40
percent or something that's incredible
which is really cool cuz like I love
acting but I do kind of get this thing
every once in a while where I'm like it
doesn't doesn't really feel like I'm
doing anything like to like you know
progress the world and stuff so it was
cool to do something that actually like
and in fact other than just making
people laugh ya know they had like a
direct effect to yeah that's awesome
oh very cool okay we're gonna take one
last break when we get back we got a
whole bunch of Twitter questions for you
we'll be right back with more not too
deep
[Music]
to do this episode not too deep is
brought to you by better help is there
something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals better help online
counseling can help they offer licensed
professional counselors for specialize
in issues like depression anxiety
relationships trauma anger family
conflicts LGBT matters grief self-esteem
and more they connect you with
professional counselors in a safe and
private online environment you can get
help at your own time at your own place
and anything you share is confidential
it's convenient you can schedule secure
video or phone sessions as well as chat
and/or text with your therapist and if
for some reason you're not happy with
your counselor you can request a new one
any time for no additional charge and
best of all it's affordable and not too
deep with grace helbig listeners get 10%
off your first month with the discount
code grace so get started by going to
better help calm slash grace fill out a
questionnaire and that will help them
assess your needs and match you with a
counselor that you will hopefully love
but that's better help calm slash grace
discount code grace okay but before we
get into the Twitter questions I'm gonna
ask you the two questions asked every
single guest that is on the podcast and
the first is who alive or dead would you
most wanna throw cold spaghetti act cool
spaghetti yeah yes I'm trying to like
I'm trying to think of like wording this
in a way we're like maybe the guy
whoever wants get hit by cold spaghetti
uh-huh like maybe someone who like
really loves spaghetti like so like a
bad person that I don't like the
intention behind the throw is entirely
up to you it can be celebratory okay
can't be like a certain place in time it
can be anything you want I'm gonna go
back and throw cold spaghetti on my face
I mean I was like a little kid on
yourself
yeah just like thank you buddy like
going back a time I'm like hi it's me
from the future
eat this freakin spaghetti
yeah I was a little brat maybe I need to
get him to Facebook or spiotti all right
would it maybe turn out to be a better
person
okay the other question that every guest
gets asked is to tell us your words
that's an amazing question by the way I
learned a lot about people and you know
their relationships with other people
yeah and this question is also very
informative please tell us your worst
pants [ __ ] story or a close call but
but you can only use three words or
three small phrases so mine is college
jogging front lawn oh boy yeah okay okay
Halloween I'm gonna I'm gonna eight
years old is gonna count as one eight
years old
gorillas cost script running and pride
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay
Twitter questions for you someone to
know what is the superior ice cream
flavor it's a superior ice cream flavor
man this is like this is the most boring
question to ask me yes because my answer
is vanilla Oh a class I know I answer
what go to vice my go to vice yeah like
sweet snacks what I'm a salty guy all
the way like okay popcorn like oh man
really I don't care like what kind of
popcorn like I'll like save like the big
large bucket and like idiot throughout
the next three days oh okay mess around
also we like 7-eleven pizza
oh yeah sitting under like a heat lamp
yeah I got really close to buying a
7-eleven hot dog yesterday no God yeah
that's I realize I'm a that's right
wrong
like like like the spicy buffalo rollers
oh yeah they're tough they're
mesmerizing that's not good on the
digestion yeah someone's to know do you
prefer bouldering or rock climbing Oh
awesome
what's the difference for someone I
don't really know bouldering is like I'm
probably gonna get skewered by the Nerds
on the internet right but to my
knowledge both bouldering is just like
you do it without ropes you don't climb
very high you climb like I think it's
like 25 feet okay
Nicole was like you know get up and over
the rock and you do have if you're smart
you have a pad beneath you mm-hmm so I
carry around a pad with me and rock
climbing there's all kinds of different
rock climbing is what I'm learning
there's like top rope there's trad
climbing there sport climbing there's
lead climbing ain't like all kinds of
stuff um I think I prefer I think I
prefer bouldering because it's you
typically have less space to climb and
the moves are harder Oh instead where
it's like rock climbing is I can Edurne
saying like I claimed like all this like
right the hardest parts of like rock
climbing or just condensed don't like
one Boulder cuz it's all like fingertip
yeah face right I have like I wish you
guys cuz yeah I have like gnarly hands
yeah weird like you've been doing a lot
of like gardening very intense really
fun massive garden hey yeah cuz that's
I've been told I'm very lanky like long
limbs and that's like good for rock
Latino it really is but my I just have
it kills my fingers anytime I've done it
which is you know maybe two times yeah
it doesn't work it never gets better
either
they also want to know what was the
first instrument you learned and which
is your favorite my first instrument I
learned it was just piano I played piano
when I was five but I like proceeded to
pick up like a bunch of really weird
instruments after that like my idols
when I was 12 years old was um
Mumford & Sons that's what an ideal man
should
you should play the banjo and should
wear a vest and a button that jeans all
the time there are way worse idols at 12
years old yeah it like sent me on really
weird path of picking up instruments
like I start playing the banjo and the
sitar and the double bass cool and my
favorite to this day is still banjo very
cool is there one that you haven't
learned yet that you would want to oh
that's a good question
um it's been so long since I've picked
up an instrument I kind of realized I'm
not super musically inclined okay but if
I could play one other I would probably
say um it's called the theremin what's I
heard that it's like when whenever you
it's a lot of movie soundtracks
especially like back in the day like um
science fiction it's like that okay yeah
and it's not used for much more than
just that oh cool yeah it's super it's
super like you could make anybody really
creepy you don't actually touch the
instrument you just move your hands and
it kind of senses where your hands are
it makes lots tones yeah really
Wow okay I got a YouTube this that
sounds nuts someone wants to know if you
had to choose one all-time favorite Luke
scenes from Modern Family which would it
be
oh man there's so so many all right
there's an episode where um Joe gets
christened and we do a whole Godfather's
booth well and Luke as stays stays home
because he's apparently sick and he like
gets out of bedding he's suddenly like
in a complete suit and then he just goes
on a rampage and like I remember the
time I really enjoyed it because I think
I was like 13 years old and they let me
like use a BB gun and like see imagine
things paid for this No yeah I think
that's stove one of my favorite scenes
that's awesome
what's been the hardest scene or episode
or oh hardest scene or episode I've
gotten think they are so many they're
like embedded in my brain that just like
I like I keep down and like I only talk
about them in therapy you know
like this really brought up some stuff
like they like changed one word and then
paragraph and then like when Z got that
word it just like your mind went blank
you couldn't do it there's a lot of
those yeah not like any of that like
particularly jump out yeah yeah like
remember the good times stay in the
positive yeah there's been a few where
like I just like I couldn't get it right
in like everyone's so like sweet arm the
show but I'm very like I'm a little
neurotic as an actor yeah you have to be
as like a young actor I'm a set of like
professionals and stuff yeah you're
proving your joke in other words right
yeah I think that's the most intense
thing that people that I'd I mean
hearing that gives me anxiety by proxy
but like I think people don't realize
like you're on a set and behind the
camera there's a whole crew of people
that are all staring at you and watching
you and you have to hit your spots and
hit your lines and all of these things
that people don't like factor into the
equation when they're just watching the
show show cost like eleven thousand
dollars a minute to shoot that number
might actually be like lower that's
great but still that's incredibly so if
you think like oh man like I mess up
yeah I make it run behind like ten
minutes like oh my god I just cost this
production that wasn't there goes my
college tuition yeah that's so gnarly
man just says I want to say hey he's a
very nice man that's not a question but
thank you to whoever that was someone
says what's it like to act for so long
on the same project super super
interesting like I go through kind of
phases where I like I you know I'm like
super super grateful and like I can't
believe this the show has gone on for so
long and then there's other times where
like I can't believe the show has gone
on for so long ten and I'm you know
gonna be turning 21 of the show next
season so no it's it's super like super
awesome that's like the dream as an
actor but it's also just like I feel so
old yeah sure
also like you don't really get a say
you know how your character progresses
you can grow so at the start of every
season you're just given kind of like
here's what here's how you are this
season yeah exactly which must be kind
of nuts I'm gonna be like how what's
gonna happen it's kind of been cool yeah
like I mean we don't even know until
like the episode of what's happening
right and they never tell us what the
season arc is and stuff but it was
definitely interesting when I was like
14 15 young through puberty and stuff
and kind of like growing up alongside
this character it was also going through
the same thing right except he was just
like a jerk she's like he really he like
they leaned hard on those like that's
also off-camera going through puberty
must have been an incredibly awkward
experience to be like so the world gets
to watch me go through puberty in a
quote character sense but I actually
yeah they were this is this is was like
a life imitates art art imitates life
thing where we're shooting an episode
about Luke texting these two girls
separately he said they were friends and
his TV sisters like join in and like try
to tell him like what to say mm-hm
and I was like this this scene cut they
actually were helping me were too textu
girl like the irony was lost on us and
everyone's like registered to a also
they give terrible girl advice ever
pulled anything from your real life and
used it in a plot on the show
they've they pulled banjo banjo so it's
actually gonna be making appearance in
our season finale I'm gonna play it cool
but other than that I don't really think
so no I know some people like they've
eric is actually a clown right and and
it's so weird to say music like you guys
like you know like a joke we're like I'm
in your clown yeah but you think he's a
clown
he's like a like a professionally
trained they took that from
Cacho that's cool but then you find out
that your final season you're an actual
rock climber yeah baby cool manifesto
yeah a lot of people asking this our
final question plans for after Modern
Family
is there I was gonna ask you see
previous where I mentioned is there any
sort of character or type or something
that you haven't played that you'd love
to like experiment with yeah I mean
obviously like you don't get much choice
as an actor are sure you get what comes
to you but yeah there's all kinds of
things I would like to do I want to do
like more serious work okay I'm like
dramas because that's actually but I
started out doing before a modern family
mm-hmm yeah I don't know I I also like
this it's like just like talking about
like like a dream role yeah it's just
some kind of like bad action maybe I
love that action man oh yeah Keanu
Reeves is my favorite actor I have not
met him you know like the whole like
don't meet your heroes thing yeah I
don't want to be oh no I'm sure he's
wonderful sure and that would actually
make it worse there's like John wick
like where he literally they kill his
dog and so he murders 200 people that's
my kind of movie and I want it I want to
be enough oh I think there's hope I
think this could happen
no one thank you for making time and
being here before you go though every
guest gets a personalized fortune cookie
for being on the podcast and spending
time with us yeah I was looking at this
because they really love eating things
I'm just gonna actually eat it okay you
might have eaten the fortune guy
actually he's really into you know
recycling in a weird way for those of
you who are at home I just pulled out
the fort on reddit ate it and I'm
currently working on swallowing it I
forget what's even on that fortune oh it
was uh it was pretty it was pretty nice
it's not gonna feel so nice
yeah it was something about being so
young and in the industry and like how
much further to go how wonderful no no I
feel like that oh man like this is all
he's got you know we really hope that
all of our guests you don't take the
fortunes to heart and you truly
literally did that yeah it's gonna be
forever part of my DNA now so actually I
think that's the nicest thing I could
have done for you guys is you're part of
me forever I'll bill you guys where can
people find you on the social media you
don't participate on on Twitter
uh-huh I don't know it's probably Nolan
Gould I think it's at Nolan underscore
gold and there's actually I'm gonna get
better about posting on that okay on
Facebook it's Nolan Gould on instagram
it's also at Nolan Gould or at free dot
no Lowe to see all of my adventures cool
thank you again for making turn this is
really me this is a lot of fun yeah well
I'm glad that you sound surprised
sometimes when you're just used to
having other people write your words for
you there you go well you did a great
job really proud of you I will see you
guys next time not too deep good bye
2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep this episode is
brought to you by better help whatever
struggles you are facing depression
anxiety trauma grief better help can
connect you with a professional
counselor in a safe and private online
environment it's convenient you can
schedule secure video or phone sessions
as well as chat and text with your
therapist and anything you share is
completely confidential and best of all
it's affordable not too deep with grace
Helbig listeners get 10% off your first
month with the discount code grace so
when I get started go to better help
calm slash grace fill out a
questionnaire to get matched the
counselor that you will love today not
too deep is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer and edited by
Melissa Dumont's writing by Diane cang a
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post production sound bike
Henry and an extra special thanks to
Flula for the theme music
[Music]